so when we fall into the dream of form
we have fear because we haven't yet
fully integrated this and when we have
fear we have ego rise up
and the ego is just an attempt to fix
this huge fear problem that rose up now
and we're all running around like you
know a bunch of kindergartners trying to
make ourselves feel better and you know
I'm I'm better now because I'm a part of
this group or I can have this object or
I can have this power you know like
whatever all the all the millions of
manifestations of ego but at the heart
our true nature is already complete love
and joy and freedom and innocence you
know we are good at our very core that
is true of all people there's so much
conditioning and not just in one human
life too we're talking about a context
that's even much bigger than not a
history that's even much bigger but from
the spiritual perspective from that
higher perspective there's complete
understanding there's complete Vision
it's like oh I see exactly why you
experienced the way you did oh wow you
actually really were Brave I mean you
see the amazing qualities of the other
and there's just so much profound love
that rises up for the other what is the
in between a human life like and is is
that essentially what you were seeing in
that pre-birth experience is the
in-between this context is very vast
so we like to narrow it down to simple
there's like Earth level and then
there's like in between level and then
tell me about that level you know
because here on Earth that's kind of how
we think of places you know well even on
Earth think of how many places there are
and we are and we're in a very limiting
system right so so I'm just saying that
as a context because the the scope of
being and the scope of activity that is
available to the soul when not limited
to an Incarnation is
unspeakably vast yeah but I but I can at
least say in my from my experience I
remember having
experiences in different layers that led
up to the choice to Incarnate and to be
a Christian
and I remember being in a realm of gold
and light I remember this being coming
to me and asking me if I wanted to go
back yet if I was ready yet and then
reviewing this life
um I had a previous Incarnation attempt
first that did not work out because I
rejected it out of fear
and anyway so that whole process takes
place in a similar level and there is
there are many different places in it
but they're they're transverse by
thought alone and tension so you just
intend or you want to be somewhere and
you're there
and there's so many different aspects of
that I can't possibly
put language on it I can say the closest
to when I actually incarnated like again
this transcends linear time too so
that's really hard really hard to speak
to but at the point that was closest to
Incarnation I was in a place that
appeared to be as an example we like
environment so I can at least describe
one environment I was in this room that
looked like a technician's chamber and
it was over the Earth and there was like
a shaft leading down to the Earth and
there were these beings there that are
like Veil application technicians
something like that
um and that place was very close
vibrationally to Earth but still you
know pre-incarnation so I still had all
my knowing I could see the Earth but I
wasn't in that layer you know I wasn't I
was not that vibrational density that
the Incarnation process is like a
plummet of vibration down down down down
down to resonate into this comparatively
very very dense uh experience by
comparison
in a way you don't really actually go
anywhere exactly that's the exactly
everything and everywhere you don't go
anywhere you just lower your frequency
down so much to
experience this super dense linear
time-consuming fear-based reality
exactly exactly you're like wow that's
the freaking that's the we're having oh
my God being a human is The Dark Knight
of the Soul itself that's that's it is
it's the it's the most dense most
opportunity offering limiting see those
are synonymous opportunity offering and
limiting are synonymous
opportunity that's handed to us and we
that's right we don't actually ever
leave
it's like the experience plays upon the
movie screen of our awareness
and we seem to be locked into it I mean
of course that's the very nature of
being veiled it seems like this is all
there is that's the name of the game but
our Consciousness is actually still
there you could say that a subset of the
self is like committed into the physical
experience but the whole self is always
outside of it it's like you could say
metaphorically it's like falling asleep
in heaven to have the dream verb you
know when you wake up in the morning you
know you never left your bed similarly
when you wake up after physical death
you know you never left you never were
in any real danger well I get very
tripped out on how the universe works
and and sort of
the fractal nature of it and how you
know there's just it's hard to put into
words I can kind of like feel this sort
of looping almost and it's like like a
black hole almost like it sucks it in
and then you know new galaxies are born
and it's like it feels like there's
almost an aspect within us that does
that and
because there's no other I'm trying to I
try and rationalize and maybe we're just
not even capable of it as human beings
so maybe it's not within our sort of
data Computing capabilities but
things like quantum entanglement and
things like I just it can't we can't
imagine that with our linear life that
we live here that something on opposite
ends of the universe can communicate
instantaneously that's because the
universe is virtual it's all being
simulated at once so the the
communication is outside of the universe
because that which is generating the
universe is already connected to itself
it doesn't need distance distances
distance is an illusion
you can think of it that way it's just
like we we believe in distance you know
a lot but distance is just a visual
experience a sensory experience an idea
it's all these forms it's a it's an
illusion
but anyway I like what you said about
the fractal nature of reality because it
very much is like that uh you know so
Above So Below you know as it said the
the quality of the spirit is such that
we do have fractals of being you know
you have the source that has
individuated into drops you have each
drop each soul that is individuated into
different personalities that appear from
a given personality's perspective is
separate but they're not separate
they're one you know you are all your
characters that you've played or the
same you
anyway so it is like that it's like a
huge fractal system within consciousness
I was just um I interviewed a guy named
uh chervin he has a cool company called
symbiotica and he's uh
he's um very spiritual and has been sort
of walking in these this is the world
for uh like since he was like 10. and we
were talking about the you know evil
forces that would be controlling the
planet and is there an Illuminati or a
cabal or is there a a deep State and
it's he described it in a way that was
like it's not that there's a group
and we kind of deduced it down to the
fact that it's like it's actually
just a macro of the micro which is that
it's an aspect within us like this sort
of like greed or materialism it's on the
micro version it's an aspect within us
and that the real solution is not
necessarily to point the finger and be a
victim it's to fix it within yourself
because when we all do that it's all
fixed absolutely the the simplest way I
feel to put that is that it's all fear
fear that is we've rejected something
we're we're not okay with something and
so we grab for control that's what the
ego does and that happens in many
different layers it happens in groups it
happens in individuals but the thing is
that that external environment is not
the active playing field for real change
I mean it will it will fix itself if
the real environment is addressed and
that is consciousness itself so the
simplest way to put that is face your
own fear
own your own crap in your life and find
the joy and the love that you already
are that got buried underneath all these
other things maybe you even got buried
at the moment you incarnated now you're
physical you don't like being separate
from everybody else that's okay find the
real you in there face to fear process
it allow it that actually helps the
entire Collective to heal because we're
all connected like we're a part of one
Pond one soup and when one of us does
that and really finds the love and
processes the fear it's like a light
that goes off for everybody else in the
pond and it raises the temperature of
the water for the whole pond so we're
not powerless you know we tend to look
external all the time oh look at the
political parties look at the laws look
at the the
face your own fear and know that there's
nothing to fear and that you are love
and you are joy and if you find that in
your life you will change the world
you'll just uh that vibration will
affect the whole world rather than being
lost in this idea of hopelessness that
we can't affect the world that's it's
not true because you said you like you
aborted the previous life to this one
because fear took over and was too much
and um so
do we choose the life that we have oh
yes parents do we choose our friends do
we incarnate with a soul family to make
it easier like how is it that we come
into the experience that we're having in
this life yeah so we absolutely choose
to come I know that that's strange when
so many people feel that their lives are
difficult and you know they're suffering
and so many people say I would never
sign up for this you know we have really
big balls when we're on the other side
we're like I got this I mean I think
that about myself as I say that to
myself regular I'm like Danica seriously
what did you sign up for what did you
what did you think that you had the
balls for okay so it's so funny because
what you just described I actually
remember doing so I remember seeing the
vibrational distance and going holy crap
that is further than I've ever done
can it even be done you know because it
was so like in my case it was a one very
specific vibration one fear that I came
to process and heal and it was so so so
vibrationally low that I was like how is
it even possible and I was told yes it
is and I just knew like if it could be
done
then I'll do then I will do it because I
know I knew what we are you know we are
unlimited Immortal beings we can't fail
we can't fail like we can't actually
fail but we can like get underneath the
weight bunch and put 150 or 200 or 500
pounds on there
and give it a shot you know and then
once we get underneath the weight that
the thing about this weight bench is
once you're strapped into the roller
coaster you can't get off you know
that's that's that but that's the name
of the game we want to be committed into
a context that we can't easily Escape
that way we have to be quote unquote
forced
to face ourselves to face our
limitations to face our fears to
overcome them to see if we can really be
there for each other in compassion and
love and kindness even when it's hard
you know so anyway we do see that
context pre-life and everybody has a
different um you know intentionality
behind their Incarnation it's very
specific to the soul and their qualities
and what they what they're interested in
and specific to the life and the context
there's a huge variety there if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen